the head of the u.n nuclear watchdog
says
reviving the 2015 iran nuclear accord
will have to wait for the formation of a
new iranian government
rafael grahae grassi says a deal will be
needed from all political parties iran's
presidential election
takes place friday in afghanistan the
taliban is not waiting for the complete
u.s withdrawal from that country to
expand its reach
tonight national security correspondent
jennifer griffin tells us the terror
group is already seizing
new territory no one knows better than
vladimir putin about afghanistan's
history as a graveyard of empires
so it was with a degree of irony that
president biden described the russian
president's well wishes on the u.s
military withdrawal
he said that he hopes that we're able to
maintain some peace and security and i
said that has a lot to do with
you the u.s military has completed more
than half of its pullout according to
u.s central command
this week alone afghan government forces
abandoned or were pushed out of six
district centers across the country
since may 1st
at least 23 districts have fallen to the
taliban
afghanistan has 34 provinces and nearly
400 districts
the taliban targeted and killed seven
afghans working for halo
a mine clearing international non-profit
so this is
a tragic indicator of the type of
violence that may be
resurfacing in afghanistan and with the
withdrawal
of the of the international troops this
is
possibly or likely going to become worse
the u.s military does not plan to
support afghan forces with air strikes
after the u.s troop withdrawal is
complete the head of u.s central command
told voice of america
in an exclusive interview after visiting
kabul that would be the reason for any
strikes that we do in afghanistan
after we leave would have to be that
we've uncovered
someone who wants to attack the homeland
of the united states one of our allies
and partners
the pentagon has not been able to define
how it will monitor events in
afghanistan
after the last u.s troop leaves defense
secretary lloyd austin told
lawmakers that u.s surveillance plants
are now flying from gulf states
once we have completed our retrograde
that will be
very difficult to do because
our capabilities will have diminished in
country among the most pressing
issues which nato member will keep the
kabul airport open
right now it falls to turkey president
biden raised the issue with the turkish
president
in brussels brett jennifer griffin at
the pentagon jennifer thank you